a traffic council's Planning and
Development Committee my name is
councilor Barrow and Stanley and I am
Vice chair of the committee before we
start getting proper can I ask if
there's anybody in the public area
intending to film the meeting
take that as a no thank you in any event
we are being broadcast on the council's
YouTube channel they're continuing on to
my left and right are Council officers
for planning legal and highways down
both sides of the table are members of
the committee who are all local
councilors and introduce them as they
speak
to the agenda
item one attendances is to note our
attendances and any apologies we have
apologies tonight from councilor Hartley
councilor Hassam councilor Shirley
Proctor and councilor akinola we've also
been advised that councilman Morgan is
running a bit late so hopes to be with
us later as substitutes we have
councilor Maitland councilor O'Brien and
councilor Kevin Proctor thank you for
your attendance counselors
item two decorations of Interest
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interact relating to any item on
the agenda in accordance with the
adopted code of conduct does any member
wish to declare an interest
thank you members item three minutes to
receive and if so determined to approve
as a correct record the minutes of the
meeting held on 16th of March 2023
proposed from councilman Thomas
anybody go to second
thank you councilor Walsh
uh question uh item four a maximum uh
questions from members of the public a
maximum of 15 minutes will be allocated
to public questions submitted in writing
to democratic Services by 4 pm on the
Working Day prior to the meeting
questions must be within the Remus of
the committee or be relevant items
appearing on the agenda and will be
submitted in the order and will be
answered in the order in which they were
submitted we've no questions this
evening
item five additional information report
to consider reports of the head of
Planning and Development which is
submitted to the meeting which has been
submitted item six applications for
permission to develop we have three
tonight the process is the same in each
case the item was introduced by a member
of the planning team
if we have speakers on the item they
then speak next members of the public
for three minutes and uh award members
for five minutes
I'll then open the item Up For Debate
and we'll then come to a decision based
on a majority vote
our first item tonight is Landis
Christie Road uh Stratford it's on page
one of your pack and Miss Lowe's will do
the introduction
thank you
[Music]
thank you okay this site is um relates
to land at Christie Road
the application site is located at the
junction of Christie Road and Chester
Road in Stratford and adjacent to the
Bridgewater Canal there's currently a
warehouse building in the North Western
half of the site occupied by a vehicle
repair center the rest of the site is
covered by hard standing for car storage
and parking with two vehicular accesses
off Christie Road
land levels fall significantly
approximately two and a half to three
meters from Chester Road into the site
with a steeply sloping vegetated area
along the Northwestern boundary the
picture on the top left-hand corner here
kind of is a picture from the road
looking down into the site and hopefully
gives you an impression of the the
change in land levels and there are
landscape buffers uh to the South and
western boundary and across the road
um on Christie Road there is in the
itron development which comprises
townhouses and apartment blocks
the application before is this evening
seeks permission to Redevelopment the
site to provide 60 affordable
residential dwellings this comprises 50
apartments and 10 three-bedroomed houses
with 38 car parking spaces extensive
Landscaping tree planting and amenity
areas within the site
it is proposed that 11 of the dwellings
would be for affordable rent with the
remaining proposed to be shared
ownership
and the development is
um the apartment block as you can see is
on on this part of the site and then we
have three blocks of houses fronting
Christie Road and within the um within
the development here
this shows the extensive levels of um
Landscaping retained along the
boundaries of the site with important
Street trees
um retained as part of the development
and Landscaping and amenity areas will
be provided throughout for the use of
the residents
the 10 houses would be three stories in
height providing front and rear amenity
and garden spaces and a roof Terrace on
one dedicated car parking space
the apartment block would be in part six
stories on the corner of Christie and
Chester roads dropping down to four and
three stories As you move towards the
canal and down Christie Road it is
proposed that the development will be
constructed in a mix of brick and
detailing work to complement that of The
Wider context
significant
significant Amendments have been
negotiated throughout the application
period and these relate to a reduction
in the number of vehicle accesses
parking and Landscaping layout the
sighting scale massing and external
appearance of the building which have
resulted in an overall reduction in the
number of dwellings proposed
a number of objections have been
received and these relate primarily to
the potential residential amenity
impacts parking levels and traffic the
amount of affordable housing and impacts
on ecology and local infrastructure
the development would provide the 88 car
parking spaces and while officers know
this is below the maximum standards set
out in spd3 they consider this to be
sufficient for the development
the location is highly sustainable with
an excellent access to trams and buses
the site is accessible for pedestrians
and cyclists with local amenities within
walking distance offering a genuine
choice of modes of Transport for
Journeys this is in line with the mppf
which seeks to focus development in
highly sustainable locations to help
reduce congestion emissions improve air
quality and public health and ultimately
the Reliance on the car
objection site concerns that overspill
car parking will occur on surrounding
streets however officers note that there
is WL lines on the Eastern side of
Christie Road a match Day Parking
restrictions in place the applicant has
come committed to funding a parking
review of parking restrictions in the
area to help limit any on-street parking
from the development
prospective residents will be aware of
the parking position before buying or
renting a flat and are unlikely to be
eligible for parking permits
this is satisfied that this level of car
parking along with the other measures
proposed or excess acceptable and the
proposal will not result in any harm
until local hiring Network parking
stresses or residential amenity
all of the detailed matters have been
assessed and the proposal is considered
to be acceptable
a section 106 legal agreement is
proposed which will secure Financial
contributions towards secondary
secondary education provision a
financial contribution towards the
review of parking restrictions within
the local area and a commitment to
retain the architect as a design
certifier
a condition would secure the
developments for 100 affordable housing
with a minimum of a level 11 affordable
rent units
the Tilted balance is engaged and the
benefits of the scheme are considered to
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the harms that would arise
the application is therefore recommended
for approval subject to conditions and
the completion of a section 106 legal
agreement thank you
thank you Miss loser everyone speaker on
this item tonight is um Mr Turner
present if you care to come up to the
microphone press the button when you
wish to speak you'll have three minutes
the timing will start once you begin to
speak if you go over the three minutes
I'll plan to ask you to to wrap up your
remarks thank you
um good evening everybody my name is
Jonathan Turner I'm the assistant
director of development at Southwest
Housing Trust and we're the applicant
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak this evening
uh just a bit about the trust the trust
is a not-for-profit housing provider and
social Enterprise we've been active
since 2007 and based locally in South
Manchester but we're seeking to grow and
invest in Trafford
as a forward-thinking community housing
company we are passionate about
providing excellent excellent homes and
outstanding customer care in our
neighborhoods
in respect of this scheme for your
consideration today
Southway are fully committed to
providing all 60 homes as affordable
to help Trafford achieve its annual
targets for affordable homes
there are a good mix of both flats and
houses and a minimum of the 11 homes
will be available for rent
with the remainder for shared ownership
these are affordable rent homes which
will be allocated via Trafford Home
Choice and offered on a priority needs
basis
as for the shared ownership homes
qualifying criteria will ensure that we
will attract both first-time buyers and
those who have a local connection to the
area
called appeal Architects have led on the
design process for this unique scheme
for us
and the apartment block is red brick a
familiar material used throughout
Trafford but it will have a contemporary
aesthetic with detailing in Champagne
colored zinc
by contrast the houses will introduce a
lighter shade of brick for diversity and
interest
each home will have a balcony Terrace or
garden
this is a leading with landscape design
that we believe built on our successful
project at Central Road in Partington
some examples of this are the seating
areas are enclosed with planted beds
there are open Lawns for both play and
relaxation
fruiting trees and a flowering Meadow as
well as benches that face the
Bridgewater canal
in all these areas create a real sense
of place and space space to breathe
areas of car parking are broken up with
bio retention Planters shrubs and trees
and as a result there will be a
significant net gain in biodiversity
a place for nature too
we've worked collaboratively with the
Authority for the past 10 months to
respect the local Heritage assets
including making key changes on the
original access points
and overall scope of the development
so that the scheme will deliver a
livable environment for the long term
in what is a growing residential
community in this location
we are delighted to have the officers
recommendation for approval thank you
thank you Miss Turner
does anyone wish to speak
Council Walsh
thanks chair
um I'm very excited about this scheme
chair 100 affordable housing I'm sure
every councilor in this room has been
approached by people and
certainly I have been written in the 20
years I've been a counselor people
desperate to live in Trafford
um we have got a shortage of housing
that's that's a fact of life
um very excited about the scheme I did
um a look through the detail today and
uh resident residents have got concerns
about it and we I have to say I was
disappointed to hear people talking
about criminality and um the value of
house prices those are not reasons to
turn down the scheme I'm I'm sympathetic
to Residents when when they've got
concerns
um I'll come to me I've got I've got a
concern with the application but I'll
just look on the on the on the good
points of the of the application that
we've got solar energy on the rooftop
here uh which I've never seen before in
a new application
um we've got lots of green space for the
residents that got are going to live
there and the design is very good and
amazing I think I prefer that to the
designer on other blocks that are not so
far away
um and it's in a very very sustainable
location you know it is near the uh the
bus stops and and the Metrolink and uh
and and the cycle Lanes as well so it's
very sustainable I'm relaxed about the
parking
um and a lot of work has gone into it
the apartment block was going to be 62
units it's down to 50.
um and and as a speaker said it's taken
10 months of work to get to this
um and it's an attractive location and
and I'm aware of the properties on the
other side of Christy Road and there
comes my concern about the application
and it is just and I'm interested in
what other members that I've got to say
but that apartment block isn't within
our SPG guidelines of 24 meters it is at
22 meters I was down there today
the building line for the apartment
block will that be the same building
line
that the warehouse has got
present there just
I'm not sure whether she'd be able to
tell me that and we might need to
have a think
but what we make what I'm getting at is
I looked at the grass verges on the
apartments on the other side and there's
a generous grass Verge there
um that is a new development and I would
argue a prestigious development
and I just got a concern are we going to
spoil it with not having a similar grass
furge on the other side of the road the
houses As you move further down
they're set back another two meters so
they do follow our SPG guidelines of 24
meters
but I think if I if I managed that I'd
have been more relaxed if the houses the
terraced houses were we were 22.
and the apartment block was 24.
I think I feel that the height of the
building makes that
uh measurement more important than
previously and um
it says in the report you know we can
where we got high density you know those
those are guidelines we we can look at
those then they're not set in stone but
I just have a concern about that I've
I've highlighted it enough I think I'm
interested in what other members think
chair thank you very much uh thank you
counselor
Miss Lowe's I might ask you to come back
on that point late in the meeting after
another counselors have spoken uh
councilman
thank you chair
um absolutely sure your opinions on the
um on the the fact that this is a
Brownfield location it's sustainable
this is affordable housing and you don't
ever get that much affordable housing or
any
um yeah hardly any of the developments
that we get
um absolutely this is perfect
um
apart from obviously the district will
get that clarified Grant ways so
um I was going to say in the objections
about obviously
um it's quite quite disconcerted by the
idea of um saying that just because the
house bringing bringing houses uh prices
down they're having as it were lower
priced houses so the people can't
actually afford to get the housing that
it was is somehow deemed you know as a
negative in in people's comments it's
quite sad really and then the idea of
that somehow it brings crime into an
area which is I don't see why it would
um so yeah I'm I mean I'm I'm mine to
support this application and um would
would be proposing to to
um to accept officer recommendation and
granted thank you
uh thank you counselor Council Thomas
thank you sir
um to design and the layout I'm more
than happy with I am concerned how well
I'll I'll go from the very positive
first there is a lift so disabled access
to all floors fantastic brilliant about
time uh developer came forward with that
included in the new build however
the downside to that there are two
accessible spaces
so we have all that exercise all that
wonderful accessibility in two spaces
I'm concerned with the number of parking
spaces there are 60 properties
for without taking out the rent people
that can either
buy share buy or
buy an affordable house will generally
have vehicles to get to and from work
I'm aware of the proximity to bus stops
and uh is set in the middle of two Trump
stops but they will have cars so I'm
concerned of that and also access onto
Christie Road from
um Chester Road uh there's going to be a
bottleneck at that inappropriate
Junction will there any any amendments
to Junction other notice that the the
highways team have said they've got no
objections yet it's it's quite a uh
having come up there today and I'm a
busy traffic day uh there are people
turning right which which causes an
issue so
though he's not going to persuade me to
go against the uh um The Proposal on the
car parking spaces I do have concern of
access because everyone's got to turn
left they can't turn right in towards
Manchester and getting onto Christie
Road from Chester Road is problematic on
that certainly at busy times
on the accessible spaces Council are you
suggesting that we request the developer
to put in more accessible spaces I would
suggest that with the excellently work
work they've done in providing the lift
I think that uh it should be encouraged
yes we we have more
at least I would say at least four
okay are you are you because the
proposal we got so far is that we accept
the
um
yeah you're happy to propose it with the
extra parking spaces can we cover that
by a condition
yeah because of that in conditions I'm
happy to second with with concerns
mentioned about the uh yeah I was going
to come back I was going to come back to
those counselor
thank you
can we deal with the the concerns that
we erased so far Miss Lowe's could you
talk a little bit about the separation
distances in the um
uh from the uh the the existing
properties that become so authorized
thank you I can yes thank you chair I
would just refer members to um some
paragraphs within the am report which
detail those but first I would just say
that in whilst we have SPD spg1 they are
um guidance and we do need to apply them
flexibly to to new developments and
coming forward paragraph 49 m94 sorry
um talks about the impact on um
across the road and it does set out that
22 meters is retained between the
apartment block and the apartment block
on the corner of um Christie Road and
Emeline Pankhurst Avenue
um
it's it is slightly below the the
guidance but it is not it's not
uncharacteristic for a high density
development like we've got here
obviously there is an additional height
at six stories but there's there's only
a small amount of apartment block that
would sit on that corner and then the
houses would sit back so officers are
satisfied that the impact would be um
minimal and there wouldn't be a
significant impact the proposed
apartment block would sit further back
in the site than the existing warehouse
and there is
um front landscaped Gardens that would
um that would be on that that Frontage
to kind of you know give give some um to
to replicate that those grass Villages
that you talked about councilor Walsh so
um I think we're satisfied that that
it's an acceptable relationship and also
in paragraph 101 of the report it also
um talks about those those separation
distances and that there is a
that 15 meters is as a distance that
would be need to be retained in order to
minimize overbearing impacts and in the
22 meters there and gives sufficient
space to to minimize that impact
um could I just add council Walsh that
the pg-1 that's referred to is rather
elderly guidance and doesn't anticipate
this kind of higher density development
is very much predicated on the sort of
suburban development that we were seeing
uh 15 20 years ago whereas as as we're
all aware the type of development we're
getting is is changed significantly and
the design guide emerging design guide
will reflect that more more accurately
in in the distances that it gives and I
do he wouldn't be seeking 24 meters
between apartment buildings thank you
uh thank you Miss Coley uh could we just
have some comments from the highways
team just to address the points made by
uh councilor Thomas and the
accessibility of Christian Rowe
could just have five minutes I'm just
looking something up on the um in terms
of the transport statement and I can
come back to respond to those questions
please uh yes yes you get a big question
two minutes will be fantastic okay okay
thank you
[Music]
um
just to to add my tube anything to this
I'm very much in favor of of this
development it is a Brownfield site uh
the I do accessibility has been
addressed as lifts have been provided to
to all floors
um I did have some concerns about the
parking but it is in an extremely
accessible location it's very close to
two uh tram stops
um it's in walking distance from uh lots
of shops and there's bus routes main bus
routes go backwards and forwards up up
Chester Road
um
I like what you did I I agree with the
points that councilor Thomas has made on
the increase in the number of accessible
parking spaces and that coupled with
everything else I will very firmly be
voting in favor of this
um so in sorry counselor you arrived
after the start of the so you can't take
part that was the point I was going to
make chairman um just while we're
waiting for the highways officers come
as I was just going to say I missed the
officer introduction so whilst I know my
colleagues will appreciate this for the
benefit of the public who are sitting
here and for the camera I am not taking
part in this debate and I will not be
voting on this item that was the point I
was going thank you again so much and as
you've made that point you'll extend
this to uh Council Welton also who
missed the introduction
okay
thank you chair um sorry about that um
yeah in terms of the the query over the
um the junction onto Chester Road
um I do acknowledge the concerns that
the members just raised but in terms of
the application itself what we have to
judge it against is what the extant
permission is so therefore given the
extent permission
um there is a transport statement
supporting the application there's
additional seven vehicles in the morning
Peak and there's a decrease of six
vehicles in the evening Peak because we
have to take on board if it was an empty
site then it would all be new trips but
because it's not a new an empty site and
it is already got a use we have to take
that on board so yes I do acknowledge
what he says but it's only a very small
increase and therefore when you model
that Junction it would only show a very
insignificant increase in terms of the
capacity or an impact on that so that's
the reason why there's no no mitigation
associated with the application
okay thank you uh so that's been
proposed and seconded that we accept our
application with the special with the
additional condition of for accessible
parking spaces or members who are happy
with that could they please indicate now
thank you and all members against
okay thank you that's just been granted
and moving on to our next item which is
the
um 12 rustic Avenue which can be found
on page 70 of the pack and Miss Milner
will give the introduction to this
thank you chair this application relates
to a two-story semi-touch dwelling on
Wassa Avenue in timpley an area
characterized by semi's attached
properties retrospective planning
permission is sort for a two-story side
and part Single part two story rear
extension
there are two recent applications for
the site which are relevant
and firstly an application was refused
in February 2020 at planning committee
but following an amendments a new
application was submitted in April 2022
and which received no objections and
therefore was approved by officers in
July 2022.
following the approval and development
commenced on site and officers were
informed that the development being
constructed was not in accordance with
the approved plans
and as a result our Enforcement Officers
went out investigated the matter and it
was confirmed that the development being
constructed did differ slightly to the
approval and as such the current
application has been submitted to
regularize the development as built on
site so for for members that have been
on site the development as built is what
is now seeking um much effective plan
and permission
and the application is being reported to
the planning committee at the discretion
of the head of planning and we have
received two objections that relate to
concerns over the overdevelopment of the
site and design in amenity and also the
fact that
um the development wasn't built in
accordance with the approved plans
initially and the frustration with with
the process
um whilst the the frustrations with the
planning process and and development
that's been undertaken is is fully
understood by offices and
what we have to consider is the
development as built and in considering
the development as constructed
um officers are satisfied that it is
acceptable in regards to design and
visual amenity and and that there would
be no harmful impacts on residential
amenity and therefore we are
recommending approval and the
presentation and currently before you
shows the previously approved
development and then if you get that one
that was the refuse scheme so we we do
consider this as an improvement on on
what has been built thank you
ah thank you Miss Milner we have one
speaker on this item is um a Santa
present
thank you so if when you begin to speak
if you switch the microphone on we'll
time three minutes from when you begin
and uh if you go over three minutes then
I'll ask you to finish your comments
sure thank you very much and evening uh
to um thank you sharing counselors and
members from the planning Authority
um so I just you know echoing one uh was
Miss Miller has said uh I was just like
to summarize uh the history of this
development
the last uh approval of the planning
application was in July 2022 while
the
client was planning for the construction
they were further advise being given by
the neighbors the number 10 and number
14 rossett Avenue and we have taken
those inputs from the neighbors and
that's why there was a slight Amendment
onto the design
the application was actually put in
almost straight after the approval in
July I think to reflect that design
um
um and I would like to point out these
three uh small differences I do
apologize I don't have a big screen uh
but basically the first thing is that we
have changed the convoluted roof design
at the back uh from a hip roof into a
monopitch roof which
um will benefit next star because the
previous design has the roof
um sliding to their side and you can
imagine the ring was it's going to go to
their side we have actually reduced uh
the first floor extension at the back by
about two meters so it's overall a
smaller footprint of the first floor
extension
um and um and basically it I can't
remember the third one
um but with that all the neighbors were
happy with the changes it's positive
change I would like to argue that it's a
better design
for for for this site and also for the
Neighbors as well and obviously it's
been recommended for approval by the
local planning Authority with that I
would obviously like to invite
you to consider to for this to be
approved thank you
uh thank you Mr Chow does any member
wish to speak
Council minutes
thank you chair so
I think the Stark thing when you go and
see it is actually the path down the
side of it between the two houses
um
it's extremely dark down there
um it's because of the side extension of
the house it has now become the wall has
become part of the where there was a
fence the wall has replaced part the
fence
um there's a slightly strange book where
the fence post sticks into the alleyway
um at the front of the house
um there's a stacker in it for some
reason and and it is I I the if if I
stand if you stand
um I don't know how many people went to
go and see it last time if you stand by
um
it's a number of 14 or is it on that
side
um on the with the blue door there you
stand there it's become so dark
um and light has been lost because if
you stand there you'll see like this
this massive brick wall is there
um
has it has it grown in the front is I
guess my question from what was actually
approved through by offices has has it
got bigger at the front because
we've got a few there's a there's like
another issue with the window there's a
window on the
um and a skylight at the back and I'm
just wondering whether those are
I think that that wasn't part of the
original application
and I've got a question about
effectively I mean the thing is there's
an application that came in it was it
came into planning committee it was
roundly refused by everybody and then
um another application came in which
tried sort to mitigate a lot of the
issues was approved through officers and
then the the applicant decided to just
go and build
you know build something that's not been
approved and then obviously come with a
retrospective less as we have had with
other applications in the past and I'm
just wondering whether
to me it seems still too too big and and
the the alleyway has gone very dark and
I feel like there's a lot there's a
public safety a problem down that that
Alleyway now and a loss of immunity to
number 14 where the where the light's
gone
um and and there's a window on the side
where there wasn't one and overlooking
into number 10
um but there's a lot of privacy there so
that can be answered that'd be great
uh I think this actually dealt within
the report but Miss Miller Miss Murder
just comment on those that'd be that
would be great thank you yes
yes thanks chair so in um paragraph five
of the the report it notes that they
that the actual
um the width of the extension has
actually decreased to the side at Ground
Floor by
um 0.3 so as approved it was 2.5 meters
wide at ground floor and slightly set in
at first floor now the development as
built is um follows the same side
building line so has been reduced by 0.3
um with that space Gibbon over to the
footpath which is
um detailed in paragraph 12 and 13 of
your report
And in regards to the skylight
do you mean
on
the ground floor extension or within the
main roof space
so which window are you
do you mean on the side elevation
[Music]
so there's two windows on the side
elevation above the footpath they are
fixture and obscure glazed and that is a
condition of this development
so it's a although it's retrospective so
we only approve um the only condition we
put on you is usually the approved plans
we have put that condition on to ensure
that those windows are fixture and
obscure glazed in perpetuity
so they look over towards number 14 they
look over the footpath in regards to the
windows on the the skylights there's one
on the ground floor extension that you
can see there
people could look up through that but we
don't consider that to be a a lot of
that's that doesn't cause overlooking
and there was a skylight on the main
roof and as covered in the officer
report that doesn't require planning
permission
thank you Miss Milner Council Morgan
uh thank you thank you chair
um I remember this coming filing
Community last time and I didn't like it
I have a feeling I voted against it last
time
um but the plans we were approved last
time so we have to compare what was
approved last time and I agree with
councilor minutes I think it's really
dark and and yeah but that with that
decision has already been made
um so I'm probably inclined to vote and
favor of it the only question I've got
is looking at all the plans and all the
commentary it seems to say that it kind
of it's taking less space sales on the
ground floor and it pulls away from the
boundary but I mean just looking at that
picture
that is on the walkway on what I presume
or is that just that the house is
effectively giving up some of its land
to the path I'm just not sure if one of
the officers could confirm that as um to
going back to paragraphs 12 and 13
that's exactly what's happened part of
the land of the applicants has been
surrendered to the footprof because of
to build a straight line the boundary
was curved so they've just used their
wall now as the boundary so the area you
can see which is tarmac the new tarmac
is the it's the kind of they've given
that to the footpath
so the footpath has essentially
increased I presume they haven't
actually given it up they're just
they they own it but they it's yeah yeah
it's it's practically given up in its
functionality rather than its land
ownership although over time that is not
something that I would even question
about I will leave that to londonership
experts
uh councilor Thomas
thank you chair
um I agree with uh both counselor Walton
and councilor minutes it is very very
oppressive uh and I would go so far to
say even number 14 is quite impressive I
get very very disappointed in these uh
we gave planning permission for a design
with uh conditions attached they've been
ignored
um
and it's just been built as is uh Mr Tao
said in his presentation that
he was mentioned to some some neighbors
it's not about neighbors uh the planning
committee so I'm I'm rather disappointed
that that the decision was taken away
from this committee that had already
passed uh previous planning having said
that
um can we really vote against this
um on the the the fact of a little bit
of loss of light and some oppression to
number 14 in terms of massing against
the very close to their back Garden I'm
not sure but uh 30 centimeters of uh
land along the side of the house where a
wall would have been a way like more
from the look of it I mean even even
pictures it it is not the most
attractive uh left-hand side of a
hallway
um though not applying consideration it
doesn't look right and we didn't get the
opportunity to opportunity to uh
debate though so I'm not sure what I am
with this at the moment thank you chair
I'll tell you where I am with this the
moment I didn't like this first time it
came around I think I voted against it
as well however what's in front of us
tonight is not different enough from
what we approved to turn it down on
those grounds and I also don't like uh
when we've given permission for
something and something different has
been built to feel a little bit like
salami slicing but we have to look at
the um the development that's in front
of us and I can't see a reason to turn
it down so on that basis I will propose
that we accept uh this Inland officer
recommendation counselor bunting
thank you chairman I think I'm more or
less in the same sort of position well
with slightly differences and I think I
remember the last time this game I think
I voted against it I believe if I
remember correctly although I would
agree with you the differences are very
small now in some ways you could argue
the differences are slightly better than
it was previously
um and slightly less of a negative
effect uh but that says maybe I
certainly don't think there's enough to
to to to Warrant a refusal so on those
grounds chairman given the fact that
it's a
a very minor uh issue I'll second the
proposal you've made thank you German
okay any absence if anybody else really
are wishing to speak it's been proposed
and seconded that we accept this could
all members uh in favor of that please
indicate
and all those against
thank you councilor I made that uh ten
to one so that we that's passed in there
and I've lost a recommendation thank you
the final item tonight is nine Blueberry
Road Bowden it's on page one of your
pack and Mrs Coley will give the
instruction
this application proposes alterations to
the front boundary treatment and the
erection of a bin store the existing
properties within the later stages of
remodeling work in accordance with
previous planning permissions
the external materials approved include
render blue engineering bricks and
aluminum planning
the front boundary wall would be 0.75
meters in height with pairs extending to
0.9 meters in height The Pedestrian gate
and vehicular access gate and adjacent
pairs would be 1.6 meters in height
pedestrian and vehicular access gates
would be cited towards the Northwestern
end of the site Frontage
boundary treatment to the same height
and general design similar materials was
previously approved under planning
permission 100 743 although with vehicle
and pedestrian access gates sighted
towards the south east and end of the
site Frontage
the gates is currently proposed would
also be set back 1.85 meters from the
site Frontage whereas the previous
approved Gates were cited on the front
boundary the bin store would be Timber
and would be cited at the Northwestern
end of the site Frontage set back from
the front boundary by 3.35 meters
the plans initially submitted with the
current application also included
proposed attached garages properties
Frontage adjacent to the common boundary
with number 11 Blueberry Road amended
plans have been received admitting this
element from the proposed scheme nine
objections were received in relation to
the original labor consultation which is
why this is in front of members this
evening but all of these raised concerns
in front of the in relation to the
garage and no issues raised in relation
to the front boundary wall or bin store
we reconsulted on the application but
unfortunately none of those applications
those objections were withdrawn which is
why the application is before you this
evening members
um officers consider the proposed means
of enclosure which would be very similar
in design and appearance to the
previously approved banded treatment is
acceptable in terms of its design and
visual immunity and would not have an
unacceptable impact on the residential
immunity of neighboring properties the
highway Authority has also raised no
objections as such it's considered the
proposed development will be in
accordance with the relevant development
plan policies and the application is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions thank you
ah thank you Mr Cody there's no speakers
tonight anybody wish to any members of
councilor Thomas
thank you chair I'm very happy it's the
the objections and the guide has been
removed all the objections to the garage
are now
uh disregarded because there's no garage
but I have to propose that we accept the
office officer's recommendation uh thank
you councilor Council bunting thank you
chairman here we are my last ever
Planning Commission
not the one
oh maybe maybe not the uh most exciting
to go out on but there we are after
about I think it's about 16 17 years on
planning committee I think there's 19
years as a counselor this is it so all I
will all I will do with that says I
agree with councilor Thomas there are no
reasons to refuse this and I will second
his proposal thank you chairman
no standing down speech no I was kidding
councilor Walsh
thanks chair very comfortable with this
application she went to look on Sunday
but
um neighbors I would imagine have
complained about about the garage and uh
one of the comments the positioning of
this garage if approved would be a major
departure on the Trafford core planning
strategy
sbd4 adopted guidance I was quoting SPG
earlier I'm just wondering is it just
can we just bottom that out spd4 adopted
guidance for extensions does it does the
garage go against that um
I wasn't particularly involved in in
that part of the proposals just
presidency this evening but as I
understand it it was officers did
um request that it was removed because
we would have refused the application on
that basis and they agreed to do so
therefore we could recommend it for
approval
uh no one else wishes to speak has been
proposed and seconded that we accept
this uh all those in favor could they
indicate please
or is that unanimous
and that concludes the business of the
committee this evening we'll switch the
cameras off shortly but can you stay
behind for five minutes afterwards just
for some uh some news that um Miss
Conley wants to share with us but before
we go
uh probably get to that point uh just to
say thank you to councilor bunting for
all the time we spent on this committee
and has given me plenty of entertaining
one-liners over the years which has been
which has been great
I'm almost about to say you I'm almost
but not quite about to say you'll be
missed
thank you
concludes the meeting
oh